what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime out Pro and today I will be
talking about one of the most polarizing
figures in the entire attack on titan
series a man who was both a ruthless
traitor and a traumatized victim of
oppression discrimination and war rhino
horn is a complex and fascinating
character a part of me really hates him
for what he has done but another part of
me also feels sorry for him because of
everything that he went through leading
up to the terrible things that he did on
Paradise Island I know from the comments
on my previous attack on Titan videos
that many people absolutely hate Reiner
and want him to die a terrible death but
I also know that there are a large
number of people who actually love
Ryder's character and for some he is one
of their favorite characters in the
entire series in this video I will be
breaking down the tragic life of Reiner
including the circumstances that led to
him becoming a warrior a survey Corps
member and a traitor I will argue that
Reiner is one of the best characters in
all attack on Titan not because I'm
excusing what he did or even because I
like him as a person I still partially
hate him
but I can also sympathize with them on a
deep level and that is precisely why
Reiner is such a great character from a
narrative perspective Reiner
evokes strong emotions within us both
good and bad while being a
multi-dimensional and multifaceted
character in fact I would argue that
both Reiner and Aaron are two of the
best fictional characters of the decade
and in this video I will explain why if
you enjoy the attack on titan content on
this channel and you want us to keep it
going please leave a like to let me know
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar please don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications you really have to
go through the trouble of hitting the
bell and then selecting that option that
says all notifications if you don't
you're definitely gonna miss a lot of
our videos it's just how you do works a
big thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons for supporting our work in May
King videos like this one possible with
D monetization false copyright strikes
and now Coppa patrons are more important
than ever so thank you guys so much I'll
talk more about patreon at the end of
this video but now let's get into it
when I almost forgot
definitely spoiler alert there will be
spoilers in this video for the attack on
Titan manga I'm covering everything we
know so far about Reiner so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned
Heine Braun was born inside the lab area
internment zone which is basically a
type of concentration camp created by
the Marlon military in order to keep the
alien population on the continent
imprisoned within one specific area this
allows the Marlins to keep the aliens
under their complete control
and while the Libero internment zone is
thankfully not a death camp life for LD
ends on the continent is still extremely
harsh and difficult the LD ends are
forced to wear armbands that single them
out from everyone else they are
discriminated against and oppressed on a
daily basis and their movements are
severely restricted by the Marlon
authorities Reiner was born to an LD and
mother and a male and father
however relationships between Marlins
and LD ins were forbidden and after eine
was born his father abandoned him and
his mother and refused to acknowledge
them his father's rejection had a
profound impact on the young Reiner he
became obsessed with earning his
father's love and he and his mother
concluded that the best way to do this
would be to join the warrior program
successful candidates of the warrior
program were granted the status of
honorary Marlins Serena and his mom
believed that once they became honorary
Marlin citizens Ryder's father would
come back and they could live together
as a family we don't often stop to think
about it but it is amazing how much we
as human beings instinctively seek the
love and approval of our parents my
father is thankfully a much better
father than Reiner scumbag dad but my
father is one of those more
old-fashioned dads who don't really show
affection very often and I remembered
that as a child I was often seeking his
approval and I felt insecure at times
because I didn't know whether he was
happy with me or disappointed in me with
that said my own experience is very
different
miners since my father never abandoned
me and he actually was always there for
me and always provided for us as a
family
so I can only imagine how Reiner would
have felt as a child not only was he
born in LDN in a place where LD ins are
looked down upon and oppressed
constantly but on top of all those
hardships his own father rejected and
abandoned him and his mother
this experience deeply traumatized
Reiner and he became obsessed with
seeking the approval of his father and
of the Malayan authorities as a result
Reiner became incredibly zealous and
extreme in his desire to become a
warrior and in his hatred for his fellow
aliens on parodies the so called Devils
on the island
Reiner convinced himself that the
Islanders were evil monsters and that he
had to destroy them all if only he could
achieve this goal then all of his dreams
would come true he would prove that the
audience on the continent are better
than those evil Devils on the island and
he would earn the love respect and
approval of his father and the other
Marlins definitely not gullible and
naive at all Reiner was determined to
become a warrior and inherit one of the
Titan shifter powers so that he could
fight against the aliens on the island
on behalf of Marlay but despite his
determination he was not one of the
strongest candidates for the position
there were others who were more suited
to inherit the available shifter powers
and Reiner was unlikely to inherit any
of them in the near future despite the
fact that you could actually see this as
a good thing since everyone who inherits
a Titan of their power is destined to
die after only 13 years
Reiner refused to listen to reason he
was convinced that if he could inherit a
Titan power he could fight against the
Devils on the island and become a hero
to the Marlins he believed that if only
he could earn the honor of becoming one
of the shifters the Marlins would accept
him and his father would finally
acknowledge him and his mother
eventually Reiner was able to inherit
the armored Titan power but it wasn't
because he was the most qualified
candidate it was because Marcel Galliard
who was the JA titan shifter at the time
influenced the Marlin military to make
Reiner the successor to the armored
Titan instead of his own brother Porco
Galliard Marcel wanted to spare
his brother the cruel fate of becoming a
Titan shifter and because Reiner wanted
to become a warrior so desperately
Marcel intervened to make that happen
when he was 12 years old
Reiner along with Marcel Bertolt and
Annie was tasked with infiltrating
Paradise Island in order to get their
hands on the founding Titan power before
heading out to the island
Reiner found his Marlin father and told
him that he had become a warrior that he
and his mother had become honorary
Marlins and that he would be bravely
fighting from our lay against the evil
LD ins on the island Reiner was hoping
that his father would be proud of him
and that he would want to live with him
and his mother as a family but Winer's
father rejected him again worse Winer's
father called him and his mother Devils
and said that his family reputation
would be ruined if anyone found out that
he had ever been involved with an LD and
woman after this further traumatic
rejection Reiner left for the mission on
parody's along with Marcel Bertolt and
any in spite of everything Reiner still
believed that being loyal to Marlay and
fighting against his fellow aliens on
the island would one day earn him the
love and respect of the Marlins once on
the island
Reiner learned the truth about why he
was chosen as the next successor of the
armored Titan power
Marcel revealed that Reiner was chosen
not because he was the best candidate
for the job but because Marcel wanted to
protect his brother Porco but Reiner
didn't have much time to deal with this
revelation because soon after telling
him Marcel was killed while protecting
Reiner from a pure Titan in an instant
the Warriors in the island were left in
enemy territory without their leader
Bertolt and Andy wanted to abort the
mission but Reiner couldn't let that
happen he blamed himself from ourselves
death after all Marcel died protecting
him from the pure Titan and so Reiner
couldn't allow the mission to fail
because of his inability to protect
himself
Reiner decided that he would take on the
mantle of leader and that he would be
the one to make sure that their mission
was ultimately a success you really have
to remember Ryan's life story up to this
point and what his mind state would have
been at this time becoming a warrior was
riders only purpose in life for as long
as
he could remember it was his obsession
because he believed that that was the
only way for him to earn the love and
respect of his father and the Marlon
society in general if he agreed to abort
the mission now he would have been
giving up his entire life the purpose
for his existence he just couldn't let
that happen so he decided to replace
Marcel as the leader of the group he
even began exhibiting certain aspects of
Marcel's personality he learned to be
commanding and assertive and he
suppressed his own feelings of
worthlessness and inferiority but deep
inside Reiner blamed himself from
ourselves death he felt that he wasn't
good enough to inherit the armored Titan
power and he eventually came to realize
that his plan to win over his father's
acceptance was probably just a delusion
eventually the three warriors
infiltrated the walls and joined the
104th Training Corps once there Ryder
continued to exhibit leadership
qualities and he became a big brother
figure to the other training corps
recruits he was known for placing the
well-being of others before his own and
he earned the respect of his comrades on
the island but something else happened
during this time
Reiner came to see firsthand that the LD
ins of the island were not Devils or
monsters they were normal people just
like the LD ends on the continent some
of them were bad people but many others
were good kind caring and friendly on
the one hand Reiner was still loyal to
Marlay and to his mission to retrieve
the founding Titan power but on the
other he realized that the propaganda he
had been exposed to for his entire life
was false everything he thought he knew
about the LD ins on the island was a lie
Reiner found it difficult to cope with
the fact that he genuinely liked and
cared for his friends within the
training corps and yet he was sworn to
hate them for being Devils and to one
day destroy them all eventually this
difficult psychological situation led to
a mental split within Reiner he seemed
to oscillate between being a loyal
warrior and a loyal member of the survey
corps the death of Marco was a major
breaking point for Einar
he was forced to brutally kill his
friend in order to protect the secrets
of his true mission but Reiner is the
type of person who puts
and others over his own safety so the
death of Marco truly broke him on the
inside
at times Reiner seemed not to know who
he really was whether he was a soldier
of the survey corps or a warrior of
Marlay this led to some extremely
strange behavior including one of the
most random major reveals in anime
history a moment where Reiner almost
casually tells Aaron that he and Bertold
are the armored and colossal Titans
ultimately the mission to retrieve the
founding Titan failed although bertolt
and Reiner were able to retrieve the JA
titan power as a result of Amir's
willful cooperation after the Battle of
shegaon China Reiner would eventually
return to Marlay without the founding
titan power and also without the
colossal and female Titan powers as
bertolt was killed and eaten by armin
while Annie remained out of commission
on the island of paradise inside her
mysterious crystal once Reiner returns
Tula Berio during an after the time skip
it is clear that he is a completely
different person than he was when he
first left his hometown rather than
perpetuating the propaganda that the LD
ends on the island were Devils Riders
outlook changed and from his
conversation with the LD ends in Liberia
upon his return it is clear that Reiner
is deliberately humanizing the
much-maligned
Islanders as time passes Reiner is
haunted by the memories of what happened
on parodies and he is also tortured by
his own sense of guilt for everything
that happened when he finally comes face
to face with Aaron once again Reiner is
a shell of a man and borderline suicidal
he tells Aaron that he just wanted to
become a hero he just wanted to be
everyone's big brother and be respected
but because of his decisions he was
directly responsible for the deaths of
thousands including the death of Aaron's
mother
Reiner says that he hates himself and he
urges Aaron to just end his life because
he can't live with himself anymore this
is when Reiner truly hits rock bottom
when all of his trauma life decisions
and feelings of guilt and inferiority
overwhelm him and crush his spirit
completely Reiner loses his will to live
at this point and if Aaron had decided
to kill him
Reiner would not have
fought back but Aaron decides not to
kill Reiner a bad strategic move in the
long run but probably a move born out of
the emotional connection that the two of
them formed as comrades when Aaron
begins wrecking havoc inside the lab
area internment zone and killing
hundreds of people riders will to live
eventually returns and he decides that
he must stop Aaron and save as many
people as possible as you can see Ryan's
life has been an emotional roller
coaster with many heartbreaking twists
and turns I can definitely understand
how Reiner came to be who he is today
and how he came to do what he did when
he helped to destroy wall Maria he grew
up in an environment where absolute
hatred for the aliens and paradise was
forced on him from a very young age and
the aliens on the island were not
presented to him as human beings but as
evil Devils who had to be destroyed
Reiner started blaming these so-called
Devil's for all of his problems and he
thought that if only he could become a
warrior and prove himself by fighting
against the devil's he would finally be
respected and accepted by his father and
a wider Marleen society this became his
obsession and singular purpose in life
keeping that in mind I can definitely
understand how Reiner came to the
conclusion that destroying wall Maria
and letting all of the pure Titans in
would be a good idea he didn't know any
better all he knew was the propaganda
that vilified and dehumanized the
Islanders Reiner genuinely thought that
by doing what he was doing he was
actually saving the world from the evil
Islanders but where I part ways with
Reiner and his logic is his decision to
continue on with the mission
after seeing firsthand that the lDA's on
the island were not bad people
when Reiner decided to stay loyal to the
Marlin army after realizing that
everything they told him was a lie when
he decided to kill Marco and to keep
being a traitor even after learning the
truth that is when Reiner lost my
respect I still think he is an amazing
character a multi-dimensional and
complex person who lived a tragic and
heartbreaking life but I cannot respect
and like him as a person because of the
decisions that he made after he learned
the truth from his own experience I can
understand the decisions that he made
back when he was just acting
false knowledge and propaganda that was
hammered into him for his entire life
but when he decided to keep supporting
Marla's military campaign after
realizing that it was all founded upon
lies Reiner became a willing accomplice
to murder and injustice that is the
moment when Reiner becomes fully
responsible for his actions and I could
never support what he ultimately chose
to do but with that said I can
absolutely understand why so many people
would love Reiner as a character and as
I said at the beginning I think that
Reiner and Aaron are two of the best
fictional characters that have emerged
in this last decade Reiner is loved by
some hated by others and both loved and
hated by many more his tragic life and
complex character invoked many strong
and sometimes opposing emotions within
us and that is exactly what a great
character is supposed to do Reiner x'
life makes us wonder whether we would
have made the same decisions as he did
if we grew up in similar circumstances
we'd like to think that we wouldn't make
the same mistakes as Reiner but do we
really know for sure faced with as much
tragedy as Reiner who knows what kind of
people we would have become it really
makes you stop and think about who you
are and how much of your personality is
really you and how much of it depends
entirely on the environment that you
grew up in on the information that you
were exposed to and the social
circumstances of your upbringing in that
complexity and uncertainty about who we
really are is captured perfectly in the
character of Heine born and that is what
makes him such an amazing fictional
character whether you love him or hate
him or a little bit of both if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more please leave a like to let me know
it really does help and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar or you just
haven't subscribed yet please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar I
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons who support us
and make videos like this one possible
special thanks to our pro hero tear
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh baby Rae nothing
but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell dress
fitted Allah beat Anatole Cassatt's ki
DJ Nathaniel and Alfa do and I can't
forget are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand above all other clans
including in grata a lowland Adam Maddie
Mac makoto-kun and the world and you
know he's serious because he didn't say
so Waldo if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value to your
life please consider becoming a patron
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]